[Music]
one of the things that's obvious anyone
who have it's a newspaper or online is
the news is that this is a very exciting
time so these are just some newspaper
headlines from the last few months and
we have kind of that going on between
different global powers who can stand
from the largest amount of money on AI
so that UK announced 1.3 billion dollars
in new announcer 18 billion now for
twenty twenty two billion dollars and
then China of course as we know who has
and the US trying to the wool
[Music]
it seems reasonable as nice pointed out
we don't have to assume that we will
necessarily achieve super intelligence
within any fixed period of time but his
team is reasonable to act on the
assumption that that's feasible a become
a new matter really whether it's a 5%
chance for an 80% chance with any any
particular time scale but it seems I
mean the converse of this is that we
guarantee that AI will fail and I have
to say in the last two years we have
seen senior established members of the
AI community publicly guaranteeing that
AI rules there
I'm enter the in for example Senior
Council apologies stood up and we
guarantee that despite the hundred
billion dollars a year that you the
public of pumping into biological
research we guarantee that you will
never ever cure cancer ever I think I
would be shocked and but seriously
that's what's happening
and I think we should just take that
denialism and the sign of insecurity
that they are worried that in fact we
might now you know clearly Isis is going
to have access to much more information
than any one human being can possibly
ingest over a lifetime and I think it's
reasonable reasonable to assume that
would be the foresight power instead
alpha0 exists as if it's on the chess
board or the go board will gradually be
extended into foresight powers in the
real world
and so will have decision-making systems
that are superior in the real world to
human beings and this is as the previous
panel pointed out something that is full
of potential for the human race because
that's what we do our civilization where
these are intelligence and we will have
much more of it and if you just take a
very prosaic measure so no science
fiction we're not talking about
uploading or infinite life extension or
fast and light travel but just bringing
the standard of living of people on
earth up to a bourgeois oacd level not
Eve not even super rich or anything like
that just ordinary bourgeois level when
you calculate the net present value of
of that advance which I think would be
relatively easy to implement with
human-level AI technology the the value
that is about thirteen thousand five
hundred trillion dollars so now when you
look at those amounts that are being
invested by the UK and France and China
they seem absolutely miniscule in
comparison to the payoff it's also worth
pointing out that since that's the size
of the prize that people are aiming for
nations companies the idea that we could
simply announce a halt to AI research
is horribly wishful thinking so it's
going to continue and it's probably
going to accelerate the question is how
do we steer it in the right direction so
we're already aware of some downsides
we've been working a lot on autonomous
weapons and and Max and others of fli
have have been enormous ly influential
in in getting this message out to the AI
community and then to the world that
this would be a really bad idea we have
discussions later on in this meeting
about the possibility of enormous
changes in the economy that would upset
the possibility of employment for most
people on earth but this is what we're
going to talk about the end of the human
race and it's worth thinking about why
better AI could make things worse and
the answer that people have pointed out
and this is not a new point is that when
you put a purpose into a machine if you
put the wrong purpose into the machine
then you have a serious problem and this
is a quote from Norbert Wiener in 1960
and he he said this in in the context of
a paper that was written in response to
seeing Arthur Samuels checker playing
program learn over the course of a
couple of days to defeat its own creator
at checkers and if you think you know
that was done on a machine with a cycle
time of I believe three milliseconds so
Norbert Wiener was really thinking ahead
in this paper and it's a pretty
remarkable paper but this same point has
been around in human civilization
actually for thousands of years so King
Midas would probably say the same thing
in retrospect right he put the purpose
into the machine that everything he
touches should turn to gold he the
machine carried out his his objective
and then he realized that included his
food and drink and we see this you know
the story of the three wishes
the third wish as always please undo the
first two wishes because I've messed up
and unfortunately with super intelligent
AI they may not be a third wish and so
we have to get the first wish right
fairly recently we started to realize
that it's actually worse than that that
it's not just putting the wrong purpose
into the machine
it's that any purpose that's put into a
machine gives the Machine an incentive
to preserve its own existence simply in
order to carry out the purpose that you
put into it so this is not some kind of
intrinsic primal instinct that we've
built into the machine of
self-preservation this is simply a
logical consequence of having a purpose
in the first place so this is the slogan
that you have to remember your takeaway
from this talk is that you can't fetch
the coffee if you did so when you
combine these two a machine that has the
wrong purpose and then self-preservation
defending itself against attempts to
interfere with that purpose you get the
plot of 2001 a Space Odyssey and you
know fortunately how in the movie is is
only somewhat intelligent if it was
really super intelligent it probably
would have terminated or unplugged all
of the astronauts on the spaceship
rather than being unplugged itself so we
have to ask right where we're investing
pretty significant sums into a
technology whose logical extrapolation
seems to be pretty problematic for the
human race and I believe that in fact we
just we made a mistake and we made a
mistake actually right at the beginning
of the field and how we conceived of
what artificial intelligence is so we
started from this idea that humans are
intelligent and even at that time so in
the late 40s early
he's the the predominant view of what we
meant by intelligence at least from the
scientific engineering community's point
of view was the ability to act
successfully right which is better than
acting unsuccessfully and so connecting
to notions of rationality a human is
intelligent to the extent that our
actions can be expected to achieve our
objectives and this is fine and then we
simply transfer that notion into
machines so we want to make intelligent
machines so this is what they have to
look like so machines are intelligent to
the extent that their actions can be
expected to achieve their objectives and
in some branches of AI these objectives
were goals in some branches they were
lost functions in some branches they
were utility functions but all AI
systems except for the extremely ad-hoc
purpose specific ones were built on this
principle and it's not just AI right you
see the same thing in control theory
where you're minimizing a cost function
same thing in operations research where
you're maximizing sum of rewards and
statistics you're minimizing loss
functions and so on so this is a primary
pillar of 20th century technology that
you create optimizing machinery and then
exogenously you specify what the
objective should be for that machinery
and then the machinery proceeds as if
that's its own objective and my argument
is that that's a mistake
we actually don't really want I mean we
could build technology like that but we
don't want it and instead we need to
switch around the possessive adjectives
right we want machines whose actions can
be expected to achieve not their
objectives but our objectives and the
difference here of course is that our
objectives are within us and they're not
within the machines and so now you have
a different problem where the machine is
trying to optimize some objective
that it's not directly aware of that
doesn't have exact access to it and then
traditionally I simply becomes a special
case where the direct access to the
objective is assumed to be correct
and in fact if we do this right we can
then have machines that are provably
beneficial despite the fact that those
two words almost seem oxymoronic right
that normally when you think about
beneficial as well what does that really
mean and it's very touchy-feely and we
all have different notions and bla bla
bla and provably is about theorems but
in fact I think we can have both at the
same time so I've been trying to boil
this down I don't think you can boil
things down into a few of them three
things so I'm boil it down into three
things number one then the robots
objective is to optimize the realization
of human preferences not of preferences
that happen to be in the machine and
number two and this is probably the most
important change is that the robot is
uncertain about what those human
preferences are and it's this
uncertainty as we'll see that gives the
Machine a very different flavor from
traditional AI systems and then third
there has to be some grounding of this
idea of human preferences in some way
for machines to have evidence about what
human preferences are and short of
telepathy the way you're going to get
information about human preferences is
from human behavior construed in a very
general sense so it could be things that
we do it could be things that we ask for
it could be the objective that we type
into the Machine right and it doesn't
have to take it literally our behavior
then is the expression of that
particular objective but any kind of
behavior provides evidence even just
sitting here listening to a talk is
providing evidence about what your
preference structures really are so
I've tried to come up with a little
picture and so this is for people who
who understand the the basic ideas of
graphical models so in graphical models
we talk about random variables and then
which ones are observed and what the
dependencies are between these random
variables and in the classic view of AI
which is which is expressed in the first
three editions of my textbook the
objective is an observable variable so
the objective is at the top and then on
the Left we have human behavior which
obviously depends on what the human
objective is and then we have machine
behavior and then the classical view the
machine gets to observe the objective
and then go about its business and in
fact you know if you understand
graphical models you realize that in
this case you can simply forget the
human behavior because the human
objective if it's observed is a
sufficient statistic for machine
behavior so the human could now be
jumping up and down saying stop you're
going to destroy the universe and the
machine says that's fine I'm just
carrying on optimizing the objective
that I know to be true and all of this
stuff coming out of your mouth about
destroying the universe is just so much
hot air okay
so this is what we want to avoid now if
we make the objective unobservable right
then we can no longer detach machine
behavior and human behavior in fact they
become tightly coupled to each other
because the objective remains unobserved
human behavior then is providing more
information about the posterior
distribution on him on what the human
objective is and therefore the two
things remain coupled so let me just go
through a few examples and more will
talk about the mathematical framework a
little bit but I just want to sort of to
give this one example to show how deeply
ingrained in our current practices of AI
this idea of the fixed objective really
is so an image classification right what
we do is we train we train up some
Sofya deep learning system or random
forest or logistic circuit or whatever
it might be with a whole bunch of images
and we minimize a loss function and
usually that loss function is a
combination of the the empirical
performance on the training set and what
we call the lost matrix the loss matrix
says what is the cost of misclassifying
an object of type a as an object of type
B okay and in an image net there are
22,000 categories so that matrix is
something like 480 million entries okay
now how many people here do supervised
machine learning or have done that in
the last 5 years let's see so quite a
lot right how many of you used a non
uniform loss matrix just a couple right
so this is standard practice
partly because when we learn to do
machine learning we're doing it on toy
problems where in fact there is no real
loss right this is just an attempt to
see how accurately we can we can get our
classifier to classify unseen examples
of course in the real world there are
differences in the losses between
different kinds of errors and so when
you accidentally classify a human being
as a gorilla that's extremely expensive
right so it probably costs Google in
hundreds of millions of dollars making
that one single mistake compared to you
know misclassifying on Norfolk Terrier
as a Norwich Terrier apparently there's
a two different kinds of Terriers I
looked at the pictures in image net I
couldn't tell the difference I don't
know who really cares about that and I
can't imagine either kind of Terrier
being that upset about about that error
so so instead right you have to think
okay we don't really know what the loss
matrix is and so no one has sat down and
typed in all 480 million entries of that
loss matrix and even if they did they'd
probably get it wrong so we have to
operate with uncertainty over the loss
matrix and that's a different kind of
machine learning than the
she learning that we've been doing so
far and the algorithm should be able to
decide for example based on that
uncertainty well okay for this case I
think it's alright to go ahead and you
know issue a classification in public so
to speak in our public facing classifier
and in other cases to say I really don't
know I'd prefer not to say what I think
this might be because it could be an
expensive mistake and in fact apparently
if you ask the Google photo classifier
now to classify a photograph of a very
obvious gorilla it will say I'm really
not sure what I'm looking at here so
they've kind of put that in by hand so
and then of course the algorithm should
then use active learning techniques to
try to refine its knowledge of the loss
matrix so that it can be more effective
in more cases let's look at another
example right so in in this view point
where the machine has radical
uncertainty about human preferences what
is it what is it supposed to do what is
it supposed to do when it's given an
instruction right now traditionally in
AI we've always taken the human
instruction as the objective right this
becomes the machine's life purpose to
carry out that objective and we've only
as in fact Norbert Wiener pointed out
we've only escaped the negative
consequences of that mindset because of
our machines are too stupid to do
anything seriously bad at least that's
been true up until the last few years
and now we've seen consequences like
okay you want to maximize click-through
sure I'll maximize click-through for you
while destroying Western democracy no
problem right so when you actually think
about what does this mean
and there's been plenty of study of this
in in
in branches of philosophy for example in
the sort of Grice Ian analysis of
requests and commands what do they
really mean so what fetch the coffee
actually means is probably something
like I'd rather have coffee there no
coffee all other things being equal
rights okay surest paribus conditions
are a fairly good way to capture what we
mean by the expression of an instruction
or request as Murli there's more to it
than that it probably also conveys
feasibility because I wouldn't have
asked for coffee if I thought that
fetching coffee was infeasible or
ridiculously expensive to achieve and
therefore the fact that I've asked for
coffee is information that it probably
isn't that expensive or infeasible to
get the coffee
now given a request like that if the
machine doesn't know for example you
know your preferences for classifying
images of gorillas is it going to be
paralyzed by that uncertainty no as long
as it can fetch the coffee without
classifying any images of gorillas
either way then that means it's still
safe to fetch the coffee so even in the
face of radical uncertainty about human
preferences machines can still be useful
because they will still be able to carry
out plans that make only sort of
minimally invasive changes to the world
and in fact if you look at this from the
other direction right so you can ask you
know why why do we have this sense that
doing nothing is generally a kind of a
safe thing obviously there are occasions
where it's not the best thing to do but
doing you know a machine that does
nothing is probably a safer thing than a
machine that acts randomly now from the
point of view of you know Markov
decision process theory doing nothing is
just one of the key actions available to
the machine and it doesn't there's
nothing that distinguishes it a priori
from the other K minus one actions but
why do we have this feeling and the
answer is I think because the universe
is not arranged randomly in some sense
the universe is sampled from the
stationary distribution that results
from a whole bunch of purposive agents
with preferences operating on the
universe and so what we see for example
you think about this row of chairs here
right I can't see any human beings
behaving here right they've all gone and
the people who put the chairs there have
all gone but the fact that the chairs
are there tells you something about
human preferences and so in fact
contrary to the philosophical view that
which is called the naturalistic fallacy
that you can't observe purpose in the
world you can observe purpose in the non
natural part of the world right because
the non natural part of world is exactly
the result of agents operating with
preferences and so so this is a paper
with anchor and row in and a few other
people here and it's an very interesting
example of how much rich preference
information is available in the world
for agents to take advantage of so let's
look at a canonical problem from the
sort of the newspaper view of AI that
somehow we can always just switch off
the machine right now in the in the
story that we see in 2001 a Space
Odyssey right how doesn't want to be
switched off and it's actually quite
difficult so in the process he offs one
of the astronauts but eventually he does
get switched off but a machine that's
sufficiently intelligent that has a
fixed objective is simply going to find
ways to prevent you from switching it
off and it's the uncertainty about
preferences that actually allows us to
switch off the machine so let's see
exactly how that works right so here's
the here's the robot and the robot has a
choice it can do something let's say
turn the world into a huge field of
computer
or something like that which it might
think is probably a good idea but
actually it's quite uncertain right so
I've I've captured that that idea by
distribution probability distribution
over the value of the action so what is
the utility of this action to the human
the machine actually really isn't sure
but let's assume that the expected value
the the average of this distribution is
slightly positive so we can also give
the Machine a choice just to commit
suicide it could say you know I'm such a
dangerous machine I should just turn
myself off and we'll define that to have
value zero because then the machine is
not going to do anything at all
now if the if these two choices are the
only things available to the machine
then it will choose to do this action it
will cover the world with computron
Yemen and finish the finish off the
human race so let's give the Machine a
third choice we can say all right it can
now wait and allow the human to switch
it off the question is why would it do
that right and in the classical view it
won't it'll have its objective and it'll
choose whichever action maximally
achieves the objective
now let's so we give the human the
choice it can switch the robot off and
then that has a value 0 or it can say go
ahead okay well what happens if the
human says go ahead it seems like we're
just back in the same situation we were
in before so what difference does this
make well what difference it makes
actually is that if the human says go
ahead it's because the action is not
terribly deleterious to the human right
so the negative part of the utility
distribution has been zeroed out ok and
now when the robot takes this action it
knows for sure that it has positive
utility for the human and if you do the
math it's very simple
you can prove a theorem that says that
in fact a robot that's designed this way
with explicit uncertainty over human
preferences is provably benefit
to the human being and so the deference
right the the fact that the machine will
allow you to switch it off that
deference comes directly from the
uncertainty about the objective and if
you eliminate that uncertainty the
deference goes away the machine will no
longer allow you to switch it off and
you have all the problems that people
envisage so even though this is a very
simple example I think this is the core
concept that is going to allow us to
have deferential but super intelligent
AI systems in the future so let's talk a
little bit about the third principle the
idea that human behavior is the source
of information about human preferences
so there's already a field called
inverse reinforcement learning which
goes back a couple of decades and the
idea is that by observing the behavior
of an agent that is presumably
optimizing some objective function some
reward you can infer what that reward
actually is and there's now a
well-established theory there are lots
of practical demonstrations of this
technology we actually want a slightly
different version of that so in in
inverse reinforcement learning or IRL
the machine is is effectively simply
observing the human through a two-way
mirror if you like the human is just
doing their thing and then the Machine
adopts whatever value function whatever
reward function it learns from the human
we don't exactly want that that works
for some tasks but for example if the
human is drinking coffee we don't want
the machine to start drinking coffee
that wouldn't be a good idea so so IRL
is that is the machine looking at the
human through the window so to speak and
learning the reward function cooperative
IRL the human and the Machine are
together in the same environment and so
this becomes not single agent AI not
machine learned not standard
machine learning or inverse
reinforcement learning but a game
theoretic situation and this seems to me
inevitable and just comes from this
coupling of human and machine behavior
so in the soil game the human has some
preferences generalized sense we'll call
those preferences theta and we'll assume
that there's some connection between
theta and the behavior it doesn't have
to be a perfect connection and then the
goal of the robot is to maximize
according to those preferences theta but
they are unknown the machine in the
Bayesian view of Searle machine has a
prior and then in in the course of the
game the prior is updated and then the
machine acts according to that so when
you solve these games all right you just
set up the game like this and you solve
it and you can put you know you can make
different environments with different
actions available you could have
communicative possibilities and so on
what you see is that the human now has
an incentive to teach the robot the
robot has an incentive to defer to the
human to ask questions and so on and so
you get I think the kinds of behaviors
that we hope our intelligent systems
will exhibit in the future and there's a
lot of technical work going on now in
this framework algorithms for solving
these kinds of games efficiently
generalizations to cases where the human
the human itself is uncertain about
their own preferences which is a common
situation in the real world and so on
we're also looking at what happens when
we generalize this to too many humans
and this is an extremely important case
obviously because there is more than one
human being in the world and then you
get into all the problems of how you
weigh human preferences and there's a
long literature on this obviously I
think going back at least to the 5th
century BC of the Chinese philosopher
moti who basically developed the first
version of egalitarian utilitarianism
wasn't very popular with the aristocracy
and so Hasan you for example has a very
famous theorem showing that any Pareto
optimal policy that's enacted on behalf
of several people is going to be a
linear combination of their preferences
and the weights in that linear
combination can depend on basically the
the opportunities that each human has to
defect from this organization and get
something better elsewhere so a
bargaining position but that made an
assumption of a uniform prior that
everyone shares so everyone has to
believe the same thing about the world
of course we don't all believe the same
thing about the world and and kritch
recently came up with this idea that you
could look at what happens when you have
different priors when people have
different beliefs about the world it
turns out in that case that you get a
very weird conclusion that the weights
that you Accord to each person's
preferences evolve according to how well
their prior predicts what actually
happens in the universe so in some sense
this says that the smart people or the
lucky people who made good predictions
about the future are going to end up
with higher weights in there in this
shared Social Welfare function and
that's a very weird conclusion to draw
and I haven't yet understood its
consequences for political theory but it
seems to be a theorem now as Peter
Eckersley pointed out in his poster
yesterday there have been many papers
over actually centuries pointing out
sort of bugs in the the simple objective
of maximizing total happiness the
utilitarian ideal and those include for
example Nozick's work on utility
monsters a utility monster is someone
whose utility scale is so large that
that their preferences end up out
weighing the Preferences of everybody
else so you might call them snowflakes
but this is a very real problem not
because I think there are utility
monsters but because everybody has an
incentive to behave as if they are you
too
you monsters so another interesting
problem is if you build robots that way
everyone's preference is equally the
first thing they're going to do is go
off to Somalia and save people's lives
who are dying of starvation which is
great except that you just paid eighty
thousand dollars for that robot and now
it's disappeared so you're not going to
be very happy about that so these are
some of the interesting things that come
up
the other interesting thing that we have
to deal with in the research agenda is
the fact that the connection between
human preferences and human behavior is
not one of perfect rationalities in fact
extremely complicated so we're trying to
invert the human cognitive architecture
so that the machines learn underlying
human preferences despite the fact that
those preferences are obscured by myopia
by group by sort of short-term thinking
by fear by emotion and so on so I'm not
going to have time because Victoria's
gonna kill me
if I explain all of those incredibly
fascinating topics I'm happy to discuss
happy to discuss those afterwards I
highly recommend actual Daniel
Kahneman's book Thinking Fast and Slow
particularly the last section which
talks about what human preference is
really are and the fact that preferences
as you experience life are very
different from preferences as you
remember your experiences from the past
and the person who chooses the future is
not the experiencing self
it's the remembering self right you
choose the future on the basis of your
memory of how different experiences
played out in the past and your memory
is simply false in many cases it seems
and you know anyone who's given birth to
children apparently has has this they
remember it as a joyful occasion despite
experiencing it as incredibly painful
and humiliating in most cases so so this
is a very complicated thing and actually
make it makes a real difference to for
example how much money we spend on
dialysis do you ask the person who's
experiencing the dialysis or the person
who is now choosing whether to continue
dialysis and you get different answers
from those
to people ok toad its to summarize I
think we have to work on the assumption
that a I will overtake human abilities
and I believe that despite that we can
have a super intelligent AI that is
provably beneficial to humans and this
is obviously a desirable technology and
I think we should stop talking about AI
safety right this is just what we mean
by AI right we don't go around saying
bridges that don't fall down we just
call the bridges right it's sort of part
of the meaning of the word bridge that
it doesn't fall down it should be part
of the meaning of the word AI that is
beneficial to the people who are
creating it otherwise it's just bad AI
right so there's a long research agenda
that we're engaged in again I don't have
time but I want to point out that this
is not the only problem that we face
write this value alignment or
misalignment problem is not the only
problem that we face there's still a
serious issue of what we call the dr.
evil problem so the misuse of AI by
someone who doesn't really care about a
value alignment or any of those things
who just wants to take over the world
it's not a new problem we have the same
thing with nuclear weapons and we have a
vast security apparatus to try to
prevent dr. evil from getting hold of
nuclear weapons and then the wall-e
problem right it's not someone misusing
ara to destroy us it's us misusing AI to
destroy ourselves in a sense of in
feeling our own civilization by handing
over its management to machines in a way
that's irreversible thank you
you
[Music]